jeudi le thème que vous avez choisi
cette semaine ce sont les 20 ans de la
maison verte créée par françoise dolto à
paris cet endroit unique a pour but de
sociabiliser les tout-petits cette
maison dans l'entrée est libre pour les
parents n'avait jamais jusqu'à présent
autorisé une caméra de télévision à
peine était dans ses murs c'est un
reportage signé benoît thévenet et
pierre laurent constants une crèche qui
n'en est pas une
ici on accueille non seulement les
enfants mais aussi les parents sur les
pas de françoise dolto
une équipe de quatre ou cinq personnes
est à l'écouté parce que ce n'est pas
évident de communiquer lorsqu'on entre 0
et 4 ans parce que le rôle de mère ou de
père est parfois difficile de la maison
la chaleur de la maison des parents
passé justement un lieu social que le
petit adam l'endroit de quelqu'un
d'autre se trace ou non rien par
quelqu'un d'autre
regarde quelqu'un d'autre la maison
versa 20 ans françoise dolto inquiété
par le mal-être de nombreux enfants à
leur entrée à l'école avait voulu créer
un lieu de transition entre la famille
le monde extérieur les foyers sont
réduits vous devez on ne voit pas les
grands mères les oncles et tantes et
cousins comme me saper ce faire la
campagne est bien les enfants sont avec
leur meilleure soirée
et puis tout d'un coup elle vraiment il
faut qu'ils fassent des courses il faut
qu'elle fasse échouer
elle met son enfant à la garderie il n'y
connaît personne en fait c'est comme si
tout d'un coup vous mettez chez les
martiens
est-ce qu'elle a peur c'est bien donc
elles voient matines donc fini les bras
de la houle ont la certitude qu'elle
reviendra les accueillantes comme ils
s'appellent eux-mêmes sont pour la
plupart psychanalyste
mais ici pas de consultation on discute
questionne on prend le temps de se poser
quelques heures chacun y trouve son
compte
on veut des questions jeu faussées
explique éventuellement un comportement
ne pas trop savoir comment réagir et là
on donne une orientation
ce n'est même pas une orientation et
john c on vous montre notre aspect des
choses
les membres de l'équipe de la maison
verte compte un travail de prévention
il ouvre les bras les yeux et les
oreilles pour éviter que l'enfant ne se
replie sur lui même qui ne sait ce qu
argote disait françoise dolto